dans cette classe de cp à l'école
élémentaire thomas pesquet de villepreux
tous les élèves participent aux
évaluations nationales des cp instauré
depuis cinq ans ce sont des évaluations
diagnostiques qui ont pour but de voir
des forces et fragilité des enfants de
façon individuelle et collective moi je
trouve que ces évaluations sont plus que
nécessaires aujourd'hui on peut mettre
un doigt sur les difficultés ou les
réussites parce que ces évaluations
canton à 100% de réussite partout c'est
aussi témoignage de quelque chose de nos
compétences
l'inspecteur d'académie des yvelines et
l'inspectrice de la circonscription ont
fait à cette occasion le déplacement
objectif voir comment se passent les
évaluations pour les élèves mais aussi
pour les professeurs une réunion avait
lieu juste avant avec les professeurs
pour faire un point et un bilan sur ces
dévaluations les outils se sont affinés
se sont stabilisés et désormais c'est
devenu vraiment quelque chose de naturel
c'est à dire que les enseignants sont
complètement confiant les familles
savent qu'on n'est pas là pour juger
mais cours n'est là pour aider et donc
le rendez-vous individuels aussi sert
aux professeurs d'appui pour échanger
avec la famille dans les yvelines ce
sont près de 18000 élèves de cp qui vont
passer ces tests jusqu'au 23 septembre
des séances d'apprentissage de la
lecture on était aussi observé sur le
département depuis deux ans une nouvelle
modalité de formation s'est mise en
place appelez le plan lecture les
enseignants de villepreux l'année
dernière ont été formés en constellation
c'est à dire en groupe d'enseignante et
elles ont travaillé ensemble sur de
nouvelles modalités d'apprentissage de
la lecture alors elles ne sont pas
partis de rien elles n'ont pas changé
complètement ce qu'elle faisait mais
elles ont enrichi leurs pratiques dans
l'académie de versailles 80% des élèves
de cp sont entrés de manière
satisfaisante dans la lecture